نور عليك شركه امريكيه للتكنولوجيا
العصبيه تعتمد على تقنيه تربط الاعصاب
والمخ البشري باجهزه الكمبيوتر من خلال
رقائق الكترونيه في قشره الدماغ حيث يتم
زرعها من خلال جهاز طبيا متخصص
تتواصل تلك الرقائق مع اجهزه الكمبيوتر
والهاتف الذكي بما يساعد على تحسين وظائف
الدماغ البشري والتفكير والتحكم في بقيه
اعضاء الجسم يتم تثبيت الرقائق بواسطه
روبوتات عندما انشائه بواسطه الشركه يديره
احد جراحين حيث يقوم بعمل فتحه بحجم اثنين
مليمتر في جمجمه الشخص وتقوم الشريحه بسبب
ثقل في جمجمه المريض تحدث الشركه بذلك الى
تقديم علاج متقدم بحالات المرضيه المرتبطه
بامراض الجهاز العصبي المركزي للانسان
والتي لا يوجد لها علاج اول تطبيقين
مستهدفين في التجارب على البشر باستخدام
سيكونان لاستعاده البصل واتاحت الحركه
لعضلات الاشخاص العاجزين عن ذلك
تامروه في ان تبدا بزرع الرقائق
الالكترونيه في ادمغه البشر خلال سته اشهر